- [Narrator] Walk into any Waffle House
and you'll be greeted by the
familiar sounds of breakfast:
Bacon sizzling, coffee
brewing, hash browns crunching,
and the piercing ding
of a waffle iron ready for more batter.
But listen closely and you'll
hear a truly unique sound.
♪ There are raisins in my toast ♪
- [Narrator] What's that?
"There are Raisins in My Toast."
Who writes a song about toast?
♪ There are raisins in my toast ♪
♪ Raisin toast at Waffle House ♪
- [Narrator] Ladies and
gentlemen, meet Shelby.
- I'm Shelby White, and I'm the
President of Waffle Records.
- [Narrator] Waffle what?
- Waffle Records is the
in-house record label
of Waffle House.
- [Narrator] Waffle Records?
Of course.
- [Shelby] Waffle Records
was created as a way
to add waffle content to the jukebox.
We originally created the songs in 1984.
Chairman said, you know what?
We need a record label.
There are currently 47 Waffle
House songs on the jukebox.
Some of our songs on the jukebox are
"Special Lady at the Waffle House."
♪ Special lady ♪
- [Shelby] "Grill Operator."
♪ I'm a grill operator ♪
- [Shelby] "I Saw Elvis
at the Waffle House."
♪ Last night I saw Elvis
at the Waffle House ♪
- [Narrator] Building a record label
all about breakfast
foods is no small feat.
So Shelby and the team
at Waffle House turned
to music producers like Jason Phelps.
- Hi, I'm Jason Phelps.
I write and produce
music for Waffle Records.
To make a song for Waffle House,
it starts with an idea.
And that idea, generally, is the title
or what the song's going to be about.
- [Narrator] Sometimes the idea
is more serious like
veterans returning home.
But, sometimes it's more silly
like having raisins in your toast.
- This last song that we did called
"Only at the Waffle House" was
very much about crazy things
that can happen at the Waffle House.
♪ Only at the Waffle House ♪
♪ That yellow light shining down ♪
♪ It's where I break from the long road ♪
People give birth at the Waffle House.
Somebody one time rode a
horse to the Waffle House.
There are lots of things that happen;
so the songs almost end up
sort of writing themselves
once you have all this good content.
We do take it very seriously
in terms of our craft,
but music is fun and
the Waffle House is fun.
Who doesn't like that marriage?
♪ Yeah, only at the Waffle House ♪